well the attack on pearl harbor
inflicted significant damage on u.s
naval assets
two thousand american servicemen were
killed 187 aircraft destroyed
18 naval vessels were damaged or
destroyed
but pearl harbor was not the knockout
blow japan had hoped for
six of the eight battleships that were
hit were were repaired and put back into
service in a relatively short period of
time
and most significantly none of the
massive and hard to replace aircraft
carriers in this fleet
had been destroyed they had been sent
away from pearl harbor on naval
maneuvers just a few days earlier
and so they escaped the assault well the
next day
president franklin roosevelt declared
december 7th quote a date
that will live in infamy unquote and ask
congress to declare war on japan
and the vote in congress was 477 to 1.
now who was that one that one was
montana congresswoman jeannette rankin
she voted the only one to vote against
she had also voted against the united
states entering to world war one i guess
she wanted to be consistent
three days later on december 11th
germany declared war on the united
states
so now that the u.s was finally in the
war now remember that the war had
started way back in september of 1939
we need to ask an important question
what was the state of the us military in
late 1941
early 1942 well the us was pretty much
where it always was at the start of a
major war
ill-prepared through all of american
history up to world war
ii the u.s fought its wars following a
basically a five-step process
step one declare war step two
realize oh no we don't have a military
we don't have an army or a navy
step three build an army in a navy very
rapidly
step four win the war step five
dismantle the military
and the u.s does this every time
throughout its wars not because it's
stupid
but because of the deeply held
republican fear of a standing army
and you may recall that we've mentioned
this idea a number of times over the
course of these lectures
for example the lecture on the election
of 1800
because americans associated standing
armies with tyranny
they kept their armies small during
peace time
now truth be told in the situation in
late 1941 wasn't quite as bad as i've
described it
or as bad as it might have been despite
anti-war sentiment that was rising
through the 1930s and upon you know that
that new
that isolationist sentiment that i've
talked about before in other lectures
and several neutrality acts that were
passed by congress to narrow the chances
of u.s involvement
in a coming european war fdr had managed
a modest pre-pre-war buildup the army
for example
had numbered only 175 000 in 1939
and it had risen by 1941 to 1.5 million
so this is a big jump but it's a far cry
from the eventual total of 16 million
servicemen and women
by 1945 so it's better than usual but
still
way short of what what america is really
going to need and remember
war is not just about soldiers and
sailors
it's about stuff now what do i mean by
that
well to fight a war you need soldiers
and sailors and you also need stuff you
need ships
tanks trucks planes guns radios
uniforms helmets boots you name it you
need a lot of stuff
and by 1941 american industry had begun
to ramp up and shake off the dust
of the great depression but it would
take time it would take months even
years in some cases
for the full power of american industry
before it was focused on the war effort
and began to churn out massive
quantities of wartime materiel
now on another note we should note that
in the immediate aftermath
of pearl harbor america was not only
ill-prepared to fight wars in europe and
in the pacific
the american people were also quite
terrified and this was especially true
on the west coast
where americans feared a japanese
invasion
this fear combined with anti-asian
racism led to calls for the removal of
all people of japanese ancestry from the
west coast
and this anti-japanese hysteria reached
such a fever pitch
that president roosevelt eventually
capitulated and in february of 1942 he
authorized the removal
of about 110 000 japanese americans most
of them american citizens
to internment camps on the interior one
of the more regrettable moments in
american history i think
the main point here is that the united
states is both anxious
and unprepared
and what about the japanese our opponent
in this war
well the situation was essentially the
reverse
japan had been building its military for
a decade and in 1941
japan possessed the largest and most
powerful aircraft carrier force in the
world it also had the world's largest
and most advanced naval air fleet
the japanese were also brimming with
confidence i mean they'd won
many quick and decisive victories over
the previous few years
including a smashing victory at pearl
harbor in december
1941. and it followed that victory it
never didn't stop after that it followed
that victory with a seizure
over the next few weeks of thailand hong
kong guam
and wake island in january of 42 japan
invaded burma the dutch east indies new
guinea
the solomon islands in february japan
sees bali
timor and singapore in march japan sees
java i mean
the list goes on and on then on may 6th
japan took the philippines which was of
course a key american possession
and this incident this fall of the
philippines included
the surrender of batan and at bataan 78
000 american and soul and filipino
troops
this is the largest surrender in u.s
history surrendered to the japanese
and then they were subsequently forced
to march to prison camps
a grueling ordeal known as the bataan
death march which killed thousands
so if you look at a map in may of 1942
you'd see that japan controlled a vast
swath of the pacific
and east asia the u.s to say the least
faced a formidable task
in taking on imperial japan